let's give this guy I'm just gonna do
basic skills you can ask me more
questions later but how begins here's
the camera app down here okay I'll hold
this so it doesn't shake around too much
okay so pretty easy to to use this you
can see that you can take still thick
pictures or videos at the moment it's on
still pictures which is why you can tell
that icon there is a camera icon so if
you take a picture if you want to use
stills that's fine down to the bottom
right corner you can take a video it's
zoomed in at the moment the actual
aspect ratio of the iPad doesn't match
the aspect ratio that you're recording
you so if you want to see the full frame
which is a bit wider than this you just
double tap and you can see the whole
thing so that's what the black bars are
about you can actually see that's in the
right ratio if you want to focus on
something that's far away or nearby you
just tap on the screen and that'll also
change the exposure so you can see I
just tapped on a dark spot so it reacts
by trying to make things bright up so
little things like that okay alright so
and then you just have to hit record you
can know you're recording because that's
gonna be flashing in time in the top
right hand corner okay and stop all
right
a funeral shortcuts there's our
multi-touch gestures to go back and
forth between things so for instance
this is your home button here so you can
use that tap it to close your out or if
you want to be fancy use four or five
fingers and you can close it okay
now the main thing I want to show you is
how to use iMovie okay so let's let's go
back for step no this is what you're
gonna meet when you first open it up
okay so to begin you want it as tap +
right it says it is pretty easy to use
but this will help things be quicker for
you what you want is a project trailers
are okay you can have a flick with
around with them but they won't be
useful for your purposes okay
now what you'll see is that you've got a
pane here which is sort of like your
preview pane which will show you you can
have a look at what the video will look
like down here you're gonna have a
timeline and up here you got the
different kinds of media you can put
into your video so at the moment because
I've got the the film right Tim roll
icon there and looking all the videos
that are currently on the
and you can get more and these are this
is still pictures so you can see I took
a few pictures this morning I'll show
you them in a second and you can add a
theme music if you like I think there's
one for I think there is one from these
reports Peters yeah I don't know it's up
to you you've got a few presets there
anyway so how do you how does it work
very easily you just pick out any sort
of clip okay for instance here's one I
took this morning of a clock ticking and
you got a few options there if you just
want to take that whole clip and adjust
it later that blue arrow icon will bring
it into your timeline and then you can
adjust what part of the actual film that
you want to quit so if I just hit play
there I'm previewing very exciting isn't
it I was looking around that star from
this morning I'm like I need some things
that move so I can feel them the clock
is moving so there you go that's that so
for instance suppose I'd like actually
you know you'll film somewhere talking
okay and art for instance like this so
let's actually do that you guys gonna
have to help me cuz I don't know how
much of my face you're gonna be able to
see but okay so someone comes into frame
and starts talking right but you won't
actually want the whole bit of the
actual video okay so what you do is stop
that okay Oh some more multi-touch
gestures if you're at four feet I think
it's four fingers you can slide across
back and forth between the apps that
you've got open so now you can see this
is then that new recording I just may
take a seat and I'm gonna actually just
gonna get rid of this hold it hold it
down and you can drag it away and it
disappears let's bring in this one so
firstly you can also see down the bottom
right this blue line that represents
your audio it's quite soft because I was
just using the internal mic so you can
adjust that and you can see there's the
volume so you can turn off you can read
you can mute the track right or you can
on sorry if I can aim right you can
boost it so you can see you see those
lines there that correspond to in the
audio so you sort of want it looking
like about that okay now it's it's
helpful having your ear there because
then you can see where you start talking
for instance so this this part here the
early part
where I'm sort of getting into the frame
and you can see it if I press play yeah
I'm just in there okay anyway so you can
see I don't want to when you guys edit
right you don't want to start over here
you actually start with the person's
there okay yeah that's a great angle
isn't it so anyway what you want to do
is tap on once onto the actual clip
you're editing and these yellow circles
at the end will let you cut it shorter
or longer so you can see I'm cutting off
the beginning and eventually oh there's
my head okay
so I'll come back a little bit perfect
yeah that's the great F the best spot to
start you can actually see as well in
the audio I can put we go a little
further because I've still got a bit of
silence there key actually make that out
or is it too small you say it yeah okay
so I go just a little bit further okay
and then at the same at the end I've got
the same problem right so I think here
that's that's yeah I disappear quite
quickly don't know
so I actually wanted to end around but
there I go okay so now I've just got
that okay so I missed the little bit so
just make it a little bit longer now you
can also see because I've only taken
this portion of that clip right up here
in the top left hand corner sorry if
that's makes it harder to see there's a
very thin you're gonna have to swing for
a thin orange line at the bottom there
cliff that shows you which parts of the
clip you're actually using in your
project okay so for instance you can you
know how we just edit and kind of cut
out a part of this clip right so you can
do that directly from up here so for
instance this is a long clip that I took
this morning of me
very exciting like I told you and that's
not for me was really born in this
morning so I thought okay I'm just gonna
clean my desk I'll show you something I
can do this in a second
but suppose you don't want to bring this
in and it can be quite long to do it
here what you might want to do is say I
just want the first five seconds 30
seconds okay so you can see you can use
these yellow circles wherever you see
them you can basically cut and change
take that pot you go sit down sit my
time
you can see there's the orange line
showing you what part of it you took and
now maybe I'm at the beginning and I
want the end so let's take that part
there so there you go beginning and you
get it okay so I actually don't want
this because it's a bit that's a bit
boring so let's put something else in
there let's take some dice okay now I
got I got given these dice for free once
what I'm going to show you now is really
quickly the transitions so in between
here between the two Clips you've got a
little icon there that tells you what
kind of transition you've got okay so I
think the default if you tap on it the
default is a cross dissolve there are
different options I'll show you in a
second so for instance when I hit play
okay so there's the dissolve okay maybe
there's also kind of cool but you know
most actual things on TV don't use any
kind of fancy transition okay so
therefore what you want to do is double
click on that and I'm hitting none and
it'll just cut from one clip to another
directly like so there yeah so no
transition okay so it's up to you what
you want to use it sort of depends on
the situation and what you're
transitioning between okay now you can
also put in pictures so I took a handful
of pictures this morning here we go yeah
it's some text books because it's pretty
boring now you'll notice these text
books of mini what's up with that well
it's kind of a nice effect when you're
looking at photos to sort of pen across
the photo and you're you've got a
voiceover talking about it so what you
might have is if you click on the
picture and the time that's there it
sits in there for five seconds maybe
that's hell I want maybe not maybe I
only want it for say three seconds okay
and what I can do is I can change what
part of the picture I'm actually looking
at okay so for instance maybe I'll zoom
into yellow fits her a because we all
love yellow fits right so that is um I'm
at the start of the picture okay so now
if I hit end okay that's what I'm gonna
look at by the end of the picture so
it's going to go from from in to out
does that make sense so if I change that
back to a fade
a bit more consistent there's a pleasure
okay no it turns out so now you're
talking about your great product that
your your story is about and then it
transitions back okay now you can see
most of what I've got it doesn't have
audio on it right so what you can do is
you've got this little icon here it's
very small which is a microphone back on
which will let you record audio over
what you've got there I can by server
basically so if you get that right
that's just telling you the audio level
if I hit record now it'll give me a
warning this is me trying to demonstrate
a really tacky looking clip and now I
really like yellow fit so I zoomed in on
the other fits and now I'm zooming away
and here's some really awesome actually
just one died it's not dice dice is
through now if I am so I'm just gonna
set that you can see what I can do now
is go back to this original one right
and it was a bit confusing having two of
me at the same time so what I'm gonna do
is take the audio in there I could
either just turn the audio completely
off right or I could make it like soft
and so you hardly hear you might be in
background away something like that so
you can play around there okay all right
now what other little features do we
want you can add in theme music I think
you can experiment with that yourself
you've one thing suppose you're done
this is my new story it's not it's
pretty awesome
I think I think we're ready to export
what you want to do is look for this
icon up here in the sort of middle top
that'll send you back to all of the
projects that you've got there and I
think what you're after is this icon
here which is sort of like it's an
export icon so probably what you want to
do is share your movie to the camera
roll and you can choose what quality
what 1080p is the highest that you can
do
the IPA because that's what it records
it okay so I could do that it takes a
while once you do it one quick thing I
want to show you because it's just
something that I learned if you've got
something and it's like a long you know
like saying for example me cleaning up
this morning okay I've got a little app
here it's a really quick and dirty way
of doing it but it works okay which will
let you speed up footage okay so it's um
it's upside down on a second that's sad
it should be sure to rotate because I
don't have um anyway this or this will
do okay now the reason why it's small is
because this app is an iPhone app so
that's why that's why it's not quite
bigger so you can tap in the bottom
right-hand corner you'll zoom in for you
and what this app lets you do is don't
don't worry about the name is take any
sort of little bit of footage and you
can edit it in a whole variety of ways
but the most important way that I like
is that I can speed things up so the
clip I had before where I was cleaning
was this one so I'll just bring that in
and I can speed it up a maximum of
double its speed so sometimes you might
want to do that multiple times that's
sometimes the time those videos you
might have seen me do that's how I do it
so this is a two and a half minute clip
so if I click on edit here that picture
of the Alpha guy running
that's my speed option so I can slow it
down I'm not going to do that because
it's boring enough or I can speed it up
so you can see it's two times there so
if I hit play really fast okay so
there's one that's one light of double
it'll take some time to export
thankfully this is not too long a clip
and then the next my supposed to be a
minute and 15 right so oh wow that's all
there's adjusting video speed Freya
please try reopening the window okay
well anyway you get the idea that's how
you do it and then you can do it
multiple times you just export a redo it
and so on okay so that's kind of your
basic tools